[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein hammerleckeres Rezept!
Ich werde Chocolate Chip Cookies machen,
also diese typisch amerikanischen
Kekse mit Schokostückchen drinnen.
Ich kenne die aus meiner Kindheit
leider nur aus dem Supermarkt,
also nicht aus Amerika,
sondern diese American Cookies,
die man eigentlich überall bekommt.
Die sind aber etwas fester und knuspriger,
aber trotzdem lecker.
Und ich mache heute eine Version
wirklich supersoft, ganz weich,
außen knusprig, innen weich.
Und es sind wirklich die perfekten Kekse!
Also geht es direkt los.
Ich zeige euch heute eine klassische Variante
und dann machen wir sie noch einmal in veganer Variante.
Denn vegan schmecken die Kekse auch super.
Und daraus könnt ihr dann noch mal eine Torte backen.
Und dann gibt es so eine Cookie-Torte,
aber die kommt dann noch, okay?
Für die klassische Version brauche ich
225 Gramm weiche Butter,
100 Gramm normalen Zucker,
einen halben Teelöffel Salz,
240 Gramm braunen Zucker,
einen Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt,
zwei Eier,
– die sind zimmerwarm –
350 Gramm Mehl,
jeweils einen halben Teelöffel Natron und Backpulver,
200 Gramm Schokodrops
– die sind backfest –
und noch mal 70 Gramm für die Deko.
Man muss schon sagen,
dass man hier schon so vom Mengenverhältnis her
fast eins zu eins zu eins
Fett, Zucker und Mehl hat.
Aber dadurch werden die eben auch außen knusprig
und innen so richtig soft.
Und man muss dazu sagen,
bei so einem Keks sieht das immer
so nach extrem viel Zucker und Fett aus,
aber, wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, so ein Marmorkuchen,
der hat auch 250 Gramm Butter,
250 Gramm Zucker,
etwas mehr Mehl als Butter und Zucker.
Aber trotzdem...
Irgendwo muss halt der Geschmack herkommen.
Und ich meine, es ist eine Süßigkeit.
Was soll's...
Wir essen ja nicht die ganzen Kekse alleine.
Aber nur so bekommt ihr die Konsistenz hin.
Denn es ist einfach so,
sobald ihr die Zuckermenge reduziert,
ist es halt so, dass ihr
diese typischen Eigenschaften nicht mehr habt,
also nicht mehr außen knusprig, innen butterweich.
Das habt ihr dann halt nicht mehr.
Und ich mische jetzt hier braunen und weißen Zucker,
weil ich dadurch wirklich diese tollen Eigenschaften habe
und auch diesen leicht malzigen Geschmack
aus dem braunen Zucker.
Also kommt jetzt hier die zimmerwarme Butter in die Schüssel.
Alle Zutaten sind zimmerwarm.
Salz und Zucker.
Der braune Zucker hinterher.
Und dann wird die Masse
mit Vanilleextrakt
erst mal für vier bis fünf Minuten cremig verrührt.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt perfekt aus.
Jetzt gebe ich ein Ei nach dem anderen dazu
und rühre es auch schön ein.
O Mann!
Ich habe gedacht, ich habe voll das schöne Bild gemacht.
Dabei habe ich total gekleckert.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich Mehl, Backpulver und Natron noch dazu,
so ein ganz normales Weizenmehl.
Dinkelmehl funktioniert aber genauso gut.
Da nehmt ihr vielleicht nur ein bisschen weniger,
weil Dinkelmehl einfach
ein bisschen mehr Feuchtigkeit braucht.
Ich wusste es.
Wie schlimm ist der Schaden?
Wie schlimm ist er?
Ach, gut. Nicht so schlimm.
Und das Mehl wirklich nur ganz kurz einrühren.
Das war es schon.
Nein, das war es noch nicht.
Jetzt nehme ich noch die 200 Gramm
Schokodrops!
Und da habe ich die backfesten.
Die sind wirklich super!
Bekommt ihr auch in jedem Supermarkt.
Und ich liebe Zartbitter.
Deswegen nehme ich die.
So ist jetzt also die Konsistenz des Teiges,
schön fest.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach ein Backblech.
Ich benutze die Lochbleche.
Da drehe ich sie sogar gerne um.
Dann habe ich einfach eine schöne glatte Fläche
ohne Rand außen.
Falls der Keks doch mal etwas größer wird,
dann wird er am Rand nämlich auch richtig schön.
Und jetzt guckt einmal.
Ich habe Eisportionierer in drei Größen.
Mit dem größten Eisportionierer bekommt ihr
richtig große Cookies hin.
Die mache ich jetzt heute nicht,
aber könnt ihr auch machen.
Und mit dem mittleren Eisportionierer, finde ich,
habt ihr die perfekte Cookie-Größe.
Und mit dem kleinen habt ihr so kleinere Cookies,
die zum Beispiel ganz gut als Tortendekoration funktionieren.
So mache ich nämlich auch noch ein paar
für meine Torte,
die ich dann noch backen werde.
Und jetzt wirklich daran denken:
Viel Abstand lassen!
Denn die zerlaufen ja noch im Backofen.
Mit der Backzeit müsst ihr echt ein bisschen variieren.
Also ich mache es so
– ich habe es jetzt natürlich schon getestet.
Und ich habe es so gemacht,
ich habe jetzt einfach mal einen Cookie drauf,
habe ihn dann im Ofen gebacken
und habe einfach geguckt, ob bei mir am Backofen
190°C Ober-/Unterhitze perfekt sind
oder ob ich doch 180°C brauche,
wie viele Minuten.
Denn der Cookie soll ja wirklich schön braun werden,
nicht zu dunkel,
innen noch etwas matschig sein.
Und da müsst ihr dann einfach einen Test-Cookie machen
und dann individuell mit eurem Backofen abstimmen.
Weil jeder Backofen backt halt anders.
Aber ich weiß es bei mir jetzt schon.
Und ich habe natürlich bei den großen und kleinen
eine andere Backzeit.
Und so könnt ihr sie dann einfach testen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich noch diese zurückgelegten Schokodrops.
Denn ich möchte ja, dass auch die Oberfläche voll ist.
Denn das kann man ja immer nicht so ganz bestimmen.
Es soll schon so ein bisschen zufällig aussehen,
aber wir überlassen es jetzt nicht dem Zufall.
Und dann drücke ich hier noch so ein paar drauf.
Und dann dürfen sie schon in den Backofen.
Und bei mir ist es so:
Die großen, also die mit dem mittleren Eisportionierer,
brauchen bei mir im Backofen etwa acht Minuten
und die kleinen etwa sechs Minuten.
[Musik]
Und die Öfen müssen vorgeheizt sein!
Für die veganen Cookies habe ich hier jetzt
einfach vegane Butter.
Da gibt es auch mittlerweile echt
ganz gute Alternativen zur herkömmlichen Butter,
auf Kokosbasis, Mandelbasis,
auch auf Sojabasis.
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Butter auf Kokosbasis.
Zucker bleibt gleich.
Alle anderen Zutaten bleiben gleich.
Und statt Ei könnt ihr jetzt entweder Apfelmus verwenden
oder einfach Leinsamen und Wasser.
Die haben nämlich beide
wirklich auch ganz tolle Eigenschaften.
Ich mache es jetzt einfach halb-halb.
Das heißt, ich bereite jetzt einmal den Teig zu,
halbiere das Ganze,
nehme für die eine Hälfte Apfelmus,
für die andere Hälfte Leinsamen.
Dann können wir nämlich auch probieren,
wie der Unterschied schmeckt.
Und ich habe auch hier die Zartbitterschokoladendrops.
Denn die sind schon von Natur aus vegan,
also wirklich keine Milch enthalten.
Bei den meisten steht zwar auf der Verpackung drauf:
"Kann Spuren von Milch" – und so weiter – "enthalten."
Das liegt aber nur daran,
dass es in der Produktionshalle durch eine Straße läuft.
Und eigentlich hat es wirklich da mit Milch keinen Kontakt.
Aber sie müssen es draufschreiben,
einfach aus rechtlichen Gründen.
Das heißt, hier ist die Zubereitung gleich.
Was ich jetzt aber schon vorbereiten werde, sind
die Leinsamen.
Die müsst ihr jetzt wirklich im Ganzen verwenden.
Also die sehen so aus.
Und die werden jetzt fein zermahlen.
Und gemahlene Leinsamen,
also geschrotete Leinsamen nehmt ihr bitte nicht.
Denn da sind schon die wertvollen Öle und Fette
und die wichtigen Bestandteile rausgezogen,
die ich eben jetzt auch dafür brauche,
dass ich es als Eiweißersatz habe.
Und jetzt kann ich hier die Leinsamen schroten.
Entweder erst mal die Leinsamen schroten,
dann mit Wasser vermischen
oder einfach direkt mit dem Wasser.
Und dann muss ich die Leinsamenmischung
etwa 15 Minuten stehen lassen.
Aber die Zeit nutze ich,
um schon mal die übrigen Teig vorzubereiten.
[Musik]
So sieht das Ganze jetzt aus,
ihr seht, noch recht flüssig.
Und das lasse ich jetzt, wie gesagt,
ganz kurz stehen zum Quellen,
bereite hier den Teig zu.
Das heißt, Butter, Zucker, Salz,
Vanilleextrakt und braunen Zucker
wirklich schön wieder cremig rühren.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
zur weiteren Verarbeitung.
Die Butter-Zucker-Mischung sieht jetzt
exakt gleich aus wie vorhin.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr entweder Apfelmus als Eiersatz
und stellt so den Teig fertig
oder, wie gesagt, diese Leinsamen
und macht damit den Teig fertig.
Ich zeige euch jetzt beides.
Deswegen halbiere ich den Teig,
damit ich einfach später den Vergleich habe.
Aber ich meine, die eine oder andere Zutat,
irgendwas von beidem hat man ja eigentlich zu Hause
oder kann man sich besorgen.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich wunderbar
ein tolles veganes Rezept.
Und dann habe ich jetzt hier einmal die Menge,
kann hier Apfel muss dazu geben.
Also gern auch einfach mit der Küchenmaschine
oder mit dem Handrührgerät weiterrühren.
Mehl, Backpulver, Natron dazu.
Ich habe die Zutaten jetzt auch schon halbiert.
Also nicht wundern.
Und die Schokolade rein.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Apfelmus-Cookies!
Und die Leinsamen.
[Musik]
Und aus beiden Teigen werde ich jetzt einfach
direkt wieder die gleichen Cookies herstellen.
Ganz wichtig ist, dass die Cookies nach dem Backen
wirklich schön abkühlen dürfen.
Das heißt, holt sie aus dem Ofen raus,
stellt sie auf die Arbeitsplatte,
lasst sie abkühlen
und dann werden sie erst vom Blech heruntergenommen,
damit sie nämlich nicht brechen.
Denn nach dem Backen
sind sie wirklich ganz weich wie Kuchen,
müssen abkühlen.
Und dann bekommen sie die schöne feste Konsistenz.
Also bis gleich!
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt die fertigen Kekse!
Wie gesagt,
gut abkühlen lassen und dann erst vom Blech lösen.
Und ich finde, rein optisch sind sie alle richtig schön.
Am besten gefallen mir optisch
die von der Farbe her.
Das sind die klassischen.
Wahrscheinlich durch das Ei.
Die haben einfach so diesen gelberen Ton.
Die mit Apfelmus finde ich aber auch megagut,
weil sie so eine schöne Struktur haben.
Die mit Leinsamen, die sehen ein bisschen aus
wie Haferkekse, finde ich, weil sie so ein bisschen flach sind.
Aber wir machen gleich die Geschmacksprobe.
Ich probiere jetzt mal ganz kurz.
Und dann hole ich gleich noch einen Veganer, den Volkan.
Der darf nämlich die zwei veganen probieren.
Und dann hole ich noch meine Freundin, die Sabine.
Die macht dann auch eine Blindverkostung.
Das heißt, ich stelle dann auch die Zutaten weg
und dann sage ich gar nicht, was was ist.
Und die probieren dann einfach und bewerten.
Also
die klassischen Cookies.
Klassische Cookies!
Die sind so lecker!
Mmh!
Vor allem außen schön knusprig
und innen in der Mitte schön soft.
Bei den
Apfel-Cookies,
finde ich, hört man schon,
dass die ein bisschen krosser sind.
Hm.
Aber auch nicht schlecht.
Echt gut!
Also die sind außen richtig knusprig.
Das hört man.
Mmh!
Und jetzt noch die mit Leinsamen.
Und die fühlen sich schon weicher an,
so ein bisschen kuchenähnlicher.
Mh.
Mh, mh, mh.
Also Apfelmus-Cookies
sind keksiger
und die Leinsamen-Cookies sind kuchenähnlicher, weicher.
Ich finde beide gut.
Vielleicht
nimmt man einfach
Leinsamen und Apfelmus.
Ja.
Okay, ich hole kurz meine Verkoster
und dann wird blind probiert.
[Musik]
Okay, Sabine, Volkan,
herzlich willkommen
in meiner Küche!
Euer Song für heute Nacht?
>> SABINE: Unser Song?
>> SALLY: Song.
>> VOLKAN: Song?
>> SALLY: Karaoke.
>> VOLKAN: Karaoke?
>> SABINE: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Ja, ihr müsst jetzt singen.
Ihr dürft jetzt.
>> SABINE: Ich habe gedacht, ich darf Kekse probieren.
>> SALLY: Okay, ihr dürft Kekse probieren.
>> SABINE: Ja, ja. Das kann ich besser als singen.
>> SALLY: Nein, singen kann sie auch.
Okay. Also ich habe Cookies gebacken.
Ihr dürft sie alle drei mal probieren.
Volkan, nur zwei bitte.
>> VOLKAN: Okay.
>> SALLY: Volkan die zwei
>> VOLKAN: Die zwei.
>> SALLY: und Sabine die drei.
>> SABINE: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und dann könnt ihr mir
einfach mal euer Feedback geben, wie sie euch schmecken.
>> VOLKAN & SABINE: Okay.
>> SABINE: Also ich breche mir einfach ein Stück ab.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ihr könnt auch ein ganzes nehmen.
Da könnt ihr so was zum Geschmack,
zum Unterschied oder so was
oder was euch am besten schmeckt.
>> VOLKAN: Crispy. Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> VOLKAN: Soft.
Soft?
>> SABINE: Also die fand ich jetzt nicht so süß wie die.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Findest du soft besser als crispy?
>> VOLKAN: Ich finde, soft ist so
– das geht...
Das löst sich im Mund.
>> SALLY: Hm. Hm.
>> SABINE: Das stimmt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah, so den Gaumen runter. Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, das ist rund.
>> SABINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du kannst noch, du kannst ruhig nehmen.
>> SABINE: Also ich mag jetzt
>> SALLY: Welche am meisten?
>> SABINE: die am meisten.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> VOLKAN: Mh.
>> SABINE: Das ist jetzt unfair, gell?
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
Zwei vegan.
>> SABINE: Hm.
Aber ich glaube...
>> SALLY: Stimmt eigentlich.
Eigentlich habe ich ja schon verraten,
dass die nicht vegan sind.
Eigentlich hätte ich dich zu erst testen und dann Vol-
Oh, ich bin so blöd!
Egal.
Aber es hat dich nicht beeinflusst, oder?
>> SABINE: Mich?
>> SALLY: Ja. Nö, nicht?
>> SABINE: Nö, mich gar nicht. Mhm.
Aber ich würde alle drei essen.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> SABINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also das sind so
>> SABINE: Die sind echt lecker!
>> SALLY: die ganz klassischen Chocolate Chip Cookies.
Die sind statt Ei mit
Apfelmus.
>> SABINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und die sind statt Ei mit Leinsamen.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
Das ist es.
>> SALLY: Das ist der Unterschied.
>> SABINE: Ja?
>> SALLY: Deswegen sind die ein bisschen weich
und die sind ein bisschen crispy.
>> VOLKAN: Crispy, ja.
Das ist auch lecker.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SABINE: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Aber, wenn das komplett gelöst ist,
das ist die Schokolade, so viel Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
Also ich finde auch, die ganz klassischen
sind so vom Geschmack her
und so von der Konsistenz her einfach,
>> SABINE: So, wie man es kennt halt, aber...
>> SALLY: wie man es kennt.
>> SABINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde die Alternativen mega, gell?
>> SABINE: Auf jeden Fall.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Einfach vegane Butter und dann Eiersatz.
>> VOLKAN: Richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich würde euch zu Hause raten,
wenn ihr die veganen macht,
dann mischt am besten Apfelmus und Leinsamen,
also wirklich so halbe Portion von allem.
Weil dann habt ihr hier
noch ein bisschen außen so dieses Knusprige,
aber das Weiche von den Leinsamen.
Ich glaube, wenn man die mischt, dann ist es perfekt.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, das kann sein. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Aber das ist trotzdem gut. Richtig toll!
>> SABINE: Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Echt cool!
Danke für den Geschmackstest!
>> SABINE & VOLKAN: Ja, danke!
>> SALLY: Und die macht ihr dann zu Hause nach, oder?
Afiyet olsun!
>> SABINE: Ja, doch.
Ich würde die nachmachen.
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> SABINE: Ja.
Vegan ist doch gesund.
>> SALLY: Ja, klar!
>> VOLKAN: Natürlich!
>> SALLY: Ballaststoffreich.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und seid schon gespannt drauf,
denn aus diesen Keksen werde ich bald eine Torte backen!
>> SABINE: Oha!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> SABINE: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Und alle Rezepte wie immer
in der Sallys Welt App oder auf sallys-blog.de.
>> VOLKAN: Danke schön!
Ich nehme den.
>> SALLY: Und wir nehmen jetzt noch die mit.
Und
herzlich willkommen in meiner Kekswerkstatt!
Und tschüss!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
[Musik]